hier j'ai appris tout comme vous moi je
suis sorti oui
si le temps de même pas le temps de me
réhabiliter vous ignorez mais j'ai
appris comme vous qui s'est passé qui a
eu une attaque pour prévu qu'il était
prêt à céder oui après moi j'y suis pas
responsable je suis plus dans le côté
artistique nous vous sorti de prison
voilà on sort de prison quand j'entends
qu'on me revendique comme le chef je
suis le chef du côté artistique c'est sa
musique tient exactement c'est ce que
j'ai vu dans les clips c'est vous qui je
suis en témoin à plusieurs actions
je vous laisserai plus d'accords mets
donc vous vous n'êtes pas responsables
de ce qui s'est passé hier maintenant
rien alors un côté nous pour accueillir
hier donc vous avez la section pour les
rodéos wave y avoir dans rien lui
d'accord lui pourquoi c'est juste que
c'est lui qui est incarcéré là bas parce
qu'on devrait lui c'est la vedette de
lyon 8e d'accord vous d'organiser un
collectif de lyon 8e pour de la musique
après
ils ont voulu me coller cette étiquette
la de du collectif c'est lui le chef de
gang et tout ça ce qui m'a suivi d'être
à l'isolément et ce qui m'a suivait
d'avoir une détention des conditions de
détention très difficiles je tenais à le
dire neuf mois très difficiles à
d'isolement ce qui m'a permis de tenir
heureusement c'est les lettres de
soutien les bouquins des librairies des
libraires des personnes des auteurs
qu'ils écrivaient
l'avocate mon avocate que je tenais à
remercier mode montrozier qui a été là
pour moi elle m'a soutenu moralement
même hors cadre du travail alain était
là c'est une bonne personne
moi en toute personne mais je n'aurais
jamais demandé de retourner lyon ou de
faire des attaques c'est bien que vous
disiez soir donc alors tout ce qui a été
fait quand vous étiez incarcéré pour
vous c'est si vous laissez pas de votre
fait moi c'est pas de ma faute c'est pas
mal en fait c'est plus plus à un élan
suspense de solidarité alors hier ils
ont voulu d'en dénoncer vos conditions
de détention les les dalton ils ont tirs
au paint ball sur le logement du préfet
ça ça fait bien entendu encore une fois
grincer des dents parce que vous sortez
prison et à sa qui se passe de joe quand
comment tu expliques ça moi j'explique
ça comme en vrai cyril c'est que ça se
passe comment il lui been sur une
injustice lui et rentrer chez lui c'est
pas s'il va se faire passer les canettes
s'il va boire le lendemain s'il va
déjeuner il en sait rien du tout
pourquoi pas ce que lui offrait lui
c'est notre vedette c'est notre vedette
à nous comme dans de partout en france
il ya dvd être jul et cetera niño ça lui
sert qu'à nous
mathieu nous
c'est moins bien que joe
abrivard
alors métaux vils vers 17 actions hier
elle était énormément décrié qu'est ce
que vous auriez à dire aux amani gt et à
tous j'ai été dur de vous ma et tromper
mais maintenant ça marche plus et c'est
pour ça que je dis oui il faut vous
insistez les faut dissoudre et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi manille d'abord
le respect que j'ai pour vous c'est que
je sais que vos conditions de détention
étaient difficiles respect mais après
regardez vous êtes à visage découvert
vous avez été condamné vous n'avez plus
rien à perdre votre collègue ils se
planquent encore derrière son masque moi
j'en ai marre vous êtes en prison
monsieur dans votre cellule vous faites
le clip dalton 2 vous participez
apologie des armes apologie de la
violence vous étiez relaxez vous étiez
j'ai cru au début vous étiez des
rappeurs des artistes vous êtes des
délinquants les délinquants une bande de
délinquants il faut la dissoudre c'est
décidé vous vous est dû à deux jours
dans ma cellule je commence bien vous
connaître la cx plusieurs fois oui
manier comment voudrais-tu alors manie
j'étais qu'est ce que vous répondez à j
bah tout simplement moi ce que je
voulais revendiquer c'était de la
musique en aucun cas ce qui se passait
dans les actions je vais pas vous dire
que je cautionne ou que je cautionne pas
je pense que ça a été un élan de
solidarité par rapport à ma détention
que j'ai passé à l' isolement maintenant
moi ce que je comprends pas aussi c'est
le manque d'impartialité parce que quand
je me faisais jugé pour des autres
affaires qui me seront revenus quand
vous voyez que le dalton plus ce
monsieur gérard darmana qui rajoutait
une couche j'avais l'impression qu'il y
avait une grosse pression qui était mise
sur moi pour me faire
vriller psychologiquement ou je ne sais
pas malheureusement j'ai tenu
mentalement je suis fort et fragile
apologie des armes apologie de la
violence quand comme c'est le cas dans
plein de clips de rap donc tu me batte
indignés de ça mais moi je pense qu'on
peut pas tout mélanger on peut pas
mettre sur un même pied d'égalité de
dangereux criminels est un collectif
d'artistes qui mène des actions kutaragi
ciment oui d'artistes c'est ce sont des
l'échalote finir coup de poing pour
faire passer des messages donc si c'est
pour dire des banalités comme la
violence c'est pas bien d'accord mais
intéressé voire presque derrière le fait
qu'ils s'habillent en dalton qui
conceptualise leur mouvement c'est aussi
pour se faire entendre et frei à des
lampadaires et médailles mais pas la
parole quand on me la donnes pas s'il
vous plaît aidez mathieu pas soit on
vous avez reçu effectivement il ya un
certain temps vous i t3 vous étiez
charmant c'était un groupe pacifiste il
n'y avait pas de violence vous voulez
faire peur à personne il ya eu un petit
rodéo pour une vieille dame mais on
s'excuse et c'est parce qu'on voulait
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est
trois ou six mois après on voit que vous
tirs au paint ball sur sur le mur
d'après fait par dont il a raison gilles
maintenant on a des voyous vous êtes
passé et je sais pas pourquoi il est
peut-être les artistes mais pour nous
les artistes s'attire pas au paintball
et je sais bien que vous trouvez vos
conditions n'aident pas les bonnes et
tout mais pardon c'est pas vous dire
faire la justice et c'est pas parce que
vous n'êtes pas contente de la justice
ou des conditions qu'il faut tirer au
paintball encore une fois ce pays c'est
incroyable tout le monde se fait justice
soi même aujourd'hui vous aurez alors le
masi rejeté les vaudois neuchâtelois
résultats lâche mèneront des actions
nous nous en tirons paint ball hockey ça
c'est de l'injustice on est des
racailles comme vous l'aurez mais quand
lui il a les neuf mois en prison et à l'
isolement c'est kiki hadji un je ne
sais pas ce que l'euro passait en
justice pour ça alors nous avons bien
géré je m'en allais je comprends alors
écouter ce que dit manu que tu me dire
madame match je me permets de te tutoyer
de balle m'a dit je comprends totalement
mois en aucun cas je leur ai demandé je
trouve de dallas attaqué le préfet de
faire des rodéos oui je comprends la
dangerosité ou je suis pas là pour
inciter à vendre de la drogue je
n'aborde année alors donc des passionnés
de l'année condamné les actions de vos
potes là maintenant condamné les airs de
solidaires
mais il peut pas condamner
des amis d'enfance et mais ils me
connaissent depuis que tu as pris peut
pas il peut pas il peut pas dit non mais
dis j'aime et je suis solidaire c'est
des amis dans sa vie à rogner les deux
il faut j'ai encore s'accélérer au
paintball sur la maison c'est comme ça
j'arrête pas de succès mais lui sait
même pas qui a tiré sur les sables il
vous êtes un groupe ça vous prend pas
part à vous êtes un groupe vous ne vous
êtes un groupe c'est tout il n'ya pas de
souci mais un collectif et l'eau et ont
effectué de parler d'un paint ball qui
tout 260 euros par
action ça veut dire derrière ce moyen
des réseaux vous avez tiré sur la ccin
ce qui veut dire vous avez tiré sur un
ventre est pas d'être actionnée vais
tirer sur des normes ce et syndicaux la
grippe alors ici l'ombre épidémie zone
qui récuse on paie prison ni à junas
violations ma vie et vous considérez ça
ne joue plus mais vous vous la
considérez la loi considéré que c'était
juste et les étoiles pour dire que vous
verrez comment vous pouvez remettre en
cause le jugement qu'a eu lieu je veux
dire il ya eu un jugement il a pris neuf
mois voilà c'est comme ça mais quand
même pas là aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
sait pas mais attendait mais on est tous
face aux lois on est tous face au juge
on est tous égaux en droits pourquoi
tout d'un coup vous pourriez aller
revendiquer des choses parce que votre
camarade a été condamné neuf mois c'est
un juge qui a décidé cet effet dans un
tribunal c'est pas à vous le faire
justice et la première chose la deuxième
chose on rentre pas dans une préfecture
avec effraction même si sa une des paint
ball on va pas tirer on vous êtes
trompés vous pensez qu'il habitait lampe
à vos collègues se penser qu'il habitait
là en l'occurrence qui n'habitait pas là
mais je veux dire un moment donné il ya
des lois vous êtes vous pouvez venir
parler ici par exemple vous avez la
parole ici vous pouvez vous exprimer ici
on n'est pas obligé de faire tout en
force si tous les gens qui sortent de
prison la justice venait de tirer dans
les commissariats ont fait comme ça chez
nous avons répondu ça je répondais on
vous a pas dit ça nous met matches aux
tours a pas d'autres le côté où il a
fait neuf morts pour rien quand je fais
neuf mois de prison il a fermé vous
n'avez pas
annie n'avait pas le droit à la télé et
remettre permettre une décision de
justice en cotisant bercy en droit de le
faire même pas le goût de la vie j'étais
laboratoire majorité pas ici haubanage
été
j'ai été condamné pour des faits des
rodéos si vous regardez tous les
pressant de mes précédents clips et je
n'ai jamais été sur une moto et je n'ai
jamais fait de la moto donc on m'a
reproché d'avoir fait des rodéos m'a
reproché des ports d'armes qui par la
suite j'ai été relaxé mais vous avez
bien comprendre j'ai toujours assumé je
vous dis pas que je suis un singe et
fait des bêtises comme tout le monde
j'ai toujours assumé j'ai jamais nié les
faits auprès des juges pour ce qu'on me
reproche mais là je trouve que c'est
quand même vous est injuste c'est sûr
que je le rappelle il a donc fait 6 mois
9 mois de détention sans remise de peine
il a passé six mois et demi en quartier
disciplinaire et en quartier d'isolement
alors que divers dess vous lire on
dirait un truc oui moi que j'ai une
question simple avons posée pourquoi
vous enlevez pas là car voilà vous
enlevez vous
avez vu pareille injustice comme manille
ben parce que je n'ai rien fait je suis
venu se placer au céleri le rachat de
justice à séoul m alexis comment enlever
la cagoule enlever la cagoule parler à
visage découvert se ménageant n'est pas
le cas quoi pourquoi pas de jeux déjà
jean pourquoi
à l'avenir enlève ta cagoule est pas ma
question mais le pire c'est que moi je
suis millions j'ai les mêmes mesures
touré et du charisme élégance mais c'est
ses pompes serbie chez par derrière ça
ne sert à rien on est venus pour faire
les new bell ok merci merci pas tout sur
les gens a dit voilà géraldine maillet
après julie alors vous venez vous dites
qu en gros vous êtes victime d'une
erreur judiciaire
c'est ça c'est maintenant j'aimerais dit
que j'étais victime djoko c'est si
j'aurais pu faire est ouverte contre
elle exige aurait pu faire autrement m'y
prendre autrement malheureusement
n'habite à lyon on n'a pas des maisons
de disques et toi toute portée de rue
donc on a fait avec les moyens du bord
avec nos moyens à nous pour essayer de
faire les sushis j'aurais pu faire avec
du recul avoir d autres plus de
professionnalisme je l'aurais fait je
dis pas je dis pas ça je voulais juste
et est ce que vous avez fait appel de
cette décision puisque c'est une erreur
judiciaire appel on a forcément
l'avocate a essayé de minimiser les
choses mais maintenant ma peine je les
assume j'ai la suite malgré
l'acharnement derrière suivent mais je
le savais mais comme vous avez dû payer
au malawi il appuie la purger sa peine
aujourd'hui je viens d'y alors je dois
juste ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent dire j'explique si c'est que
c'est une peine voilà c'est la première
fois en fait que ça arrive on repense
une telle prime voilà pourquoi une cité
de rodéo la cendre qui n'existaient pas
donc voilà ils ont jugé que la peine
était trop sévère le rapport voilà à ce
qu'ils avaient fait gilles verdez c'est
indéniable on a fait on a fait du chef
des dalton un exemple on vous a jugé
pour l'ensemble de votre oeuvre sur les
faits en eux-mêmes c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement sévère mais ça moi je le
reconnais bien volontiers
juste juste moi je pose la question mais
gilles n'a dit non mais il a dit many
many l'a dit et il comprend c'est mal
c'est vraiment très bien ce qu'il a fait
est ce qu'ils ont fait hier il est pas d
ce n'était pas de son fait et c'est
juste pas non mais juste les mecs on a
on a parlé cette semaine d'un truc on a
vu
le jeune homme qui appelait à laquelle
appellent au meurtre sur jean michel
blanquer
il a été a été relaxé injuste voilà j'ai
eu l'arrivée rien on à la personne qui a
emmené un 9 sur
la personne qui a giflé emmanuel macron
la prix moins que manager teilleur
dossier on connaît tous le dos non non
non non mais je vous dis non non rien il
ya des gens qui seraient prêts sur les
bécanes et eux c'est les premiers et je
suis non moi je
le dirai des gens qui nous attend là
s'il avait pu se payer comme nous un
avocat à 700 euros de l'heure alors je
pense pas qu'ils auraient fait une telle
peine g8 a commis d'office qui sort de
l'école évidemment c'est
un beau cadeau de départ des quatre que
j'ai c'est normal
non jules personnes les cherry pour ceux
qui nous regardent c'est pas une chose
et je pose la question que c'est pas des
afférents je te crois c'est une affaire
moi ce que j'aime c'est ce que
l'abaissement qu'en studio 700 euros de
l'heure comme nous non t'as pas compris
ce que je voulais dire que cher que
quand on fait quand vous aurez côté
journée de 700 euros de l'heure non ce
que je voulais dire c'est que si tu peux
te payer un très bon avocat
effectivement c'est plus facile de
diminuer la peine que c'était a pas les
moyens de se payer un bon ami juif mais
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît aussi
ont battu déjà si on distingue justice
il a fait neuf morts c'est bien que on
n'a pas les moyens de venir à paris
prendre le poste est ce que vous
attendiez ce que je viens de dire je te
demande est là les meilleurs prix chez
nous s'il vous plaît non mais c'est pas
c'est pas connu on explique le début de
la fin on s'est tous et pour que les
gens qui nous regardent
alors mal
m guillaume genton s'il vous plaît mais
moi je joue pendant peu plus
supportable avec eux on a le commissaire
pernikoff le juge de l'ormeau qui sont
là pour rappeler la part dont on a droit
de remettre en question de condamnation
comme l'a dit série la défense il s'est
également alarmé effectuera la raison à
l'irrigation de condamnation de
s'interroger sur la news sur le des
charges sur le paraître le château à la
chaux tenir tu fais actuel alors me
direz il a droit de dire que sa peine et
brouillard il assume ça j'ai lu ar bed
quoi me colle excuser on a parlé de
plein d'affaires ici je me souviens de
la sphère quesada tout le monde a donné
son avis oui c'est trop lourd c'est pas
assez lourd tron s'est rien passé ses
nerfs sur les daltons tout le monde la
loi de donner son avis lui moi vous
romantique
et moi je voulais digit amer
condamnation elle était extrêmement
lourde c'était un
vrai bon j'ai regardé ses bambins
nicolau parle pas sur les autres je
voulais juste dire un truc on le dit et
même ne cautionne pas moi je parce que
il faut voir un truc c'est que les gens
qui étaient là préfecture voilà il est
je sais pas si les gens ils ont du
flipper forcément
c'est sur c'est quoi qu'il ait fait des
mois le départ avec fouace et ils ont dû
avoir une énorme peur le préfet il a dû
on a dû lui dire tiens on a essayé
peut-être de faire une action contre toi
aujourd'hui voilà ça a été c'est ça
franchement on peut pas l'excuser
maintenant je disais juste jeu je disais
juste il nous explique depuis le début
que c'est une peine qui n'avait jamais
été donné avant voilà c'est juste moi
c'était complicité de rodéo ça a été un
signal mais eux se pose la question
parce qu'ils voient ce qui se passe dans
d'autres affaires et ils disent est ce
que voilà c'est juste pour sa manie
j'étais c'était vraiment complicité de
rodéo c'est ce qu'on a eu et sa
complicité de rondot c'est exactement ça
assez d'accord oui juliette les rodéos
il ya eu beaucoup d'affaires l'année
dernière de rodéo ça peut tuer des gens
bien sûr et des victimes de rodéo donc
c'est pas anodin donc oui c'est sûr à
faut à mon avis vous avez été condamné à
juste titre la justice s'est bien passé
vous êtes passé vous avez vous n'avez
pas fait appel c'est dommage pour vous
maintenant vous sortez de prison avec un
bracelet électronique à la cheville si
je ne m'abuse d'ailleurs je sais pas si
vous avez vraiment le droit d'être là
vous devriez vous faire tout petit
monsieur et faire et faire et faire acte
de repentance n'est pas la place au
lendemain du rejet que tendrement c'est
l'acharnement qu'il a eue suite à cette
détention en isolement vous êtes est ce
que vous êtes à la tête d'un collectif
de réaliser mon gamin qui monte qui
tirent sur des bâtiments publiques mais
normalement ses pickups s'en faut
arrêter de venir pleurer ou vous les
condamnez vous fait tout petit et vous
voilà vous fait preuve de repentance
vous arrêtez de plus si lui même y sinon
assez content du
groupe mathieu oui enfin paris atteint
groupe c si
j'arrêtais dire je sais pas qui c'est
donc on condamne pas condamner beauvau
vos amis qui eux aussi sont en groupe je
peux dire ce que veut dire mathieu et ça
il ya plein de gens peuvent le
comprendre ils disent dans la tête des
gens et manie j'étais le chef du groupe
donc s'ils manient j'étais dit arrêtez
vos actions arrêtez vos rodéos sauvages
et arrêter de faire des actions contre
la préfecture avec ses draps ça va être
le signal et de la solidarité comme ce
qui se passe encore oui mais si jamais
il ya des lois cyril il fait pas un
mètre 95 il fait pas 145 kilos de muscle
s'est passé je me sens très cher si ça
lui vaut d'être le chef du gang non mais
c'est quoi tout cas d'un art chinois lui
c'est bien aimé lui c'est le bien aimé
lui c'est nous donne est donc c'est
passé non c'est pas le siège aurait bien
aimé maintenant les chefs des chefs en
quoi lui dans le côté musical artistique
voilà c'est ça ça consultant avec le
leader le leader du groupe musical mais
on entend le gang on entend collectif au
nom d'allah tout ça est quand même assez
nébuleux moi je veux savoir ce que vous
êtes dépassés par la base enfin oui si
vous avez peur de rentrer chez vous si
vous parlez ça c'est une vraie question
non c'est peu dire au
président que vous ne savez pas dire ami
d'enfance je peux dire c'est ce qui me
plaît ce qui me plaît je peux tout dire
après le silence est d'or le survêt
saidal tonnes d'or ça c'est une chose
tout ce qui retient les dalton mais moi
en l'occurrence je ne veux pas me
permettre de dire que je suis le chef de
tout ce qui se passe et j'apprends comme
vous ce qui se passe avec les laisser
facile parce que du coup personne n'est
responsable cher jamais acheté vous vous
êtes et vous avez la même tenue
personnage de macho en fait vous savez
qu'on la police a de siracourt et ben
c'est un trou mais cela revient mais
messieurs plusieurs écoles est en train
de dire que tu peux pas venir chez
khakassie surtout ma tête je tape à la
porte mais owen direct à payer des
couilles au moins d'être un gouffre
solidarisant veut revendiquer quelque
chose on est tous ensemble mais là c'est
moi je sais pas ce qu'il a fait je ne
connais pas n'y a pas de chef pour les
chacun et chaque série robin n'est pas
le métier valeurs portées par le même
costume jo jo et emmanuel je pense que
vous lui aurez rue rendue beaucoup plus
services en faisant une autre action
réaction ou peut-être que ça parce que
ça je pense que ça voilà où ça fait que
mettre de l'huile mettre de l'huile sur
le feu dire voilà que là où on vous a
traité de voyou gilles verdez voilà et
c'est
d'ailleurs ça en disant on va faire des
actions tromper dans la phase de
l'action vous avez fait vous avez fait
une action vous nous avez fait une
action qui était top la dernière fois
quand vous avez vous avez fait une
action que les acteurs je vous ai fait
une collecte exergue ref là c'est vrai
que faire un trou plus drôle voilà là
c'est vrai que la jouer je vous dis
attaquer là la préfecture même au
paintball sirec forcément ça
vous allez pouvoir parler de ma musique
comme image
d'un abruti
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette année bien sûr va
perdre du poids
en
play off les hauts plateaux
moi je suis quelqu'un qui respecte la
loi maman je râle t une heure hier j
entre nous social vous comprenez non
s'il vous plaît on arrête ça on arrête
ça j'aurai la nimani dit nous y voilà
moi ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que ça sert à rien de s'en porter comme
ça dont à la futilité maintenant moi ce
que je vais vous montrer c'est mon côté
professionnel lâchant préparation de
gros projet musical et qui cette fois
j'espère m'ont choqué la france dans le
bon sens assez sympa on préfère ça on le
connaît et on en connaît au maire ni au
préfet non embargo beta alors alors se
soit fait un appel à vos autres dalton
pour leur dire arrêtez de ce genre
d'actions qui avaient aimé cyril son
école là c'est ça ce qui est très
choquant les gars vous arriver il ya des
gens qui sont rentrés qu'on fait peur à
tout le monde avait quand même une bonne
oui c est la raison et on arrête les
futilités j'ai un album qui sort alors
manon marchan les mains quand même c'est
pas là d'accession
c'est toujours moi j'ai toujours parlé
musique
s'est passé c'est pas bien au nom adam
braz et le légat cessa année le mais
vous devez y ait quoi que ce soit si mes
lordi le mets même lukinda n'y a pas de
problème
on va aller de ton coton n'y a que moi
qui étais content de moi j'agis certains
ménages est ce qu il a vécu neuf mois la
manic gt
non mais si moi moi ce que j'aimerais ce
que j'ai envie que vous fassiez la
première à hemani j'étais bien ou pagnes
moi je préférais voilà que vous arrêtiez
toutes ces actions là près c'est tout ça
que vous vous prenez le contre-pied de
tout ce que les gens disent contrôler et
que vous fassiez un album qui va tout
déchirer dans lequel vous allez
peut-être raconter les injustices que
vous avez vécu ce que vous avez vécu au
placard et ça et qu'on dise la prochaine
fois les dalton ils font plus de rodéo
ils font plus de paint ball contre la
préfecture externe et ils ont fait un
album qui est un truc de fou que sa
façon de faire et
qui m'intéresse bah alors avec les
moyens du bord si on aurait eu des gens
qui nous ouvre des portes peut-être que
vous pourrez me donner un coup de mains
plus tard pour essayer de me diriger
je te laisse pas que oui je te quelle
faction petit peu ric-rac autre nom mais
non mais non mais au-delà de ça il faut
que vous disiez oui à tous les jeunes
parce que et tous les gens qui vous
suivent pas ce que j'explique tout le
monde peut dalton en fait c'est ça
l'histoire c'est ça qui fait sens pas
expliqué comment n'est que demain il ya
des mecs qui ne connaissent pas qui vont
toutes les tenues des dalton et passez
vous dire voilà et je menais ont fait
partie du collectif dalton y connaissent
pas ou les gars mais si ce soir vous
dites nous on veut faire juste la bonne
musique et on veut arrêter de faire
voilà donc d'être connue pour des tours
d d d d d m'aider mais voilà d d d d d
action des actions qui sont contre la
loi et qui sont hors la loi là je pense
que ça va vraiment beaucoup joué
notamment des guerrières abati peu c'est
exactement ça nous mais on veut pas
d'injustice non vous a pas de gens
malheureux au jeu rien malige
était un obstacle qui puisse faire mais
amélie son album et
citoyens et vous devez nous on veut être
derrière lui à faire des sinois
s'il vous plaît
soyez des bons citoyens sera un match
assez longtemps belles lunettes ça je
l'entends et manie j'étais vous voyez
mon et de la vie un instant si soit
voilà je vous dis en vérité si je vois
que tout se passe bien que voilà vous
avez voilà je vois que les daltons il
faut que des bonnes actions qu'ils ont
changé qui font pleuvoir ça hier c'est
une connerie mais cette histoire de
préfecture
c'est une connerie je suis désolé c'est
une connerie salut pop sénat veulent ça
nous porte préjudice à lui porte
préjudice alors ça c'est qu'entre le
maire du bruit mais là oui oui c'est ça
semble bien je si je me rappelle bien et
j'étais à l'intérieur en prison avec des
bras mais je ne sais pas vous mais moi
je vous dis pas que c'est toi mec au
niveau collectif je me donnais des
conseils franchement chedjou et violent
j'ai lavé le rafraîchir l'été les cibles
parce que là le les daltons la tenue ça
n'a pas du tout la parra pour encore à
inscrire la tenue regardais les plus
jeunes étaient plus jeunes que l'honneur
on n'a pas les moyens des mecs costauds
en
prison nous
que vous paraissent beaucoup alors que
je vous ai jamais vu arrêtez arrêtez de
faire des actes de la mres à ramallah
vers les intervenants n'est pas madame
ne veut pas [ __ ] la merde tu ne fais
pas pour 3 n ya vraiment deux déjà il ya
mc des innocents en prison voulons
diriger une somme ça évolue mais moi je
peux en prison chez hopley julhes de
rihanna parce que je fais pas de la
merde